hi there uh steve kaufman here uh today
i want to talk a little bit about uh
linguistics and and language learning
related research
and the impact this has had on language
learning
now
some of you may have seen my recent blog
post that the linguist on language my
blog
where i referred to some research
in i think with holland where they came
to the conclusion that
watching movies
with the subtitles in the target
language is better for you than watching
movies
with the subtitles in your own language
and we should reassess what we do or
something and and i just think that is
such a useless
absolutely useless bit of research
because
most people when they
look at subtitles it's because they
don't understand the language
so that the general message there is
very misleading now in their particular
experiment they had some people who were
trying to get better at understanding a
scottish accent and
if the subtitles were in english rather
than in dutch they somehow did better
which even that to me is very silly
because eventually they'll just listen
more and more and they'll get it and it
probably really doesn't matter an awful
lot it might be marginally better if the
subtitles are in
english rather than dutch who cares
what i'm struck with in all of this is
that you know i'm not against science
i think that the modern world i feel
very lucky to live
uh today when in today's day and age i'm
not one of these who feels that we've
you know we're destroying the planet and
so forth i mean thanks to science we
live longer there's more people alive
today than by far than at any time in
the past and that includes places like
africa
uh
where they have you know certain
economic you know development problems
but even there their uh
health uh
circumstances and longevity and size of
the population uh means that we're
healthier now than we ever were thanks
to science
and i have seen you know thanks to uh
you know the scientific method
uh not only uh have we got uh you know
uh
pharmaceuticals that keep us alive and
uh cure diseases we have airplanes we
have uh
you know
the internet
all the things that that we're
surrounded with which give us a
tremendous i think
uh no
everything has its pluses and minuses
and it may put stress on us and maybe
when we were happier maybe we were
happier when we were sitting by a dusty
roadside
uh talking with our friends maybe but
that's a matter of opinion i'm happy
with the way we are so i'm not against
science
but if i look at the results of let's
say a hundred years of all kinds of
scientific research into linguistics and
language learning and then there are
sources that are quoted that go back 100
years
and certainly in the last 50 years
the gnome chomsky's with his to my mind
ridiculous theory that
we are born with an innate grammar
i mean since i speak 11 languages
i don't see how you can possibly say
that we have in all languages we have
names for things we have names for
people
we have words for
actions we have words to describe these
but i mean some some languages have no
tenses some languages have no the words
don't change some languages there's a
lot of
different declensions some languages
allow a double negative some don't some
have articles some don't i mean it's
just so varied from language to language
so you know i prefer to believe that the
brain is very good at picking up
patterns whatever that might be
but nevertheless so we've had all of
this science
and research
and uh i mean linguistics every
university has its linguistics
department and they're doing all kinds
of research and there's i mean if you
look up you know on the
web you know linguistics dictionaries i
mean there's like hundreds of them and
each thousands and each of these
dictionaries has thousands of terms in
them terms that nobody understands
except the few that are involved but
what has been the net effect on language
learning
uh
you know i gather that a high percentage
of people who live in ethiopia speak two
three four five languages
i bet you they haven't a clue about
linguistics in ethiopia i am sure that
that none of those people learned
as a result of
some research that was done
about language learning and of course
all the research that's done is it seems
to contradict somebody else's research
some research research shows that
correcting you helps some other research
shows that it doesn't help and depending
on how the study group is selected and
the parameters and definitions of the
study they can just about prove anything
and does it really matter i mean i read
my russian books
uh
you know tolstoy war and peace
the aristocrats in russia they all spoke
fluent french
you know my parents grew up in
czechoslovakia in fact they were born in
the austro-hungarian empire
getting close to 100 years ago
they spoke german czech
french english
they didn't have
the benefits of all this research they
learned why did they learn because they
were surrounded by the language they
were exposed to a lot of the language
perhaps they had some traditional method
of of teaching it doesn't really matter
they heard the language and they were
they had what moses mccormick referred
to is that they had that open-mindedness
that said this is important i'm going to
do it
you know
it seems to me that a lot of the
research takes place in english-speaking
countries the united states
england new zealand all kinds of
research on language learning
those are the countries that seem to
have the fewest number of people who
speak other languages
when i see what's happening here in
canada we have immigrants surviving
and i don't think the immigrants learn
languages better now than they did 50
years ago probably a lot worse
we've got a tremendous
industry of people who were doing
research and they spent 10 years for
example developing the canadian language
benchmark system and now everything has
to conform to that and people don't
learn as well as they used to and the
fundamental reason for this is
that language learning is something that
depends on the learner it doesn't depend
on the teacher it doesn't depend on
uh research it depends on the learner if
the learner wants to learn the learner
will learn
however by listening by speaking by
making mistakes by going to class
whatever they choose to do
is up to the learner and so the learner
50 or 100 years ago or in ethiopia or
500 years ago that was motivated to
learn learned so i i believe
that this all of this research is a
waste of time
i will just let this ring and my wife
will pick it up
and what's more i think it's
counterproductive because it leads to an
over complication of language learning
all of these terms linguistics terms
uh
attempts to come up with new games to
play in the classroom knew what the
canadian benchmarks thing had they
referred to task based learning and
tpr
dprs it's all fine and dandy but we
don't need it because fundamentally all
of those things are built around the
idea that
the research is going to show us how the
teacher should teach
and really the stress should be on how
do we learn
and there if you're motivated to learn
you will learn
and in fact
the biggest impact
of of science and technology and
research on language learning
is the tremendous advances
in
the internet in you know mp3 technology
the availability of of
radio and television stations and movies
in different languages the way we can
travel i mean
technology has created
a world
that enables us now i mean in the old
days as as we said in our link video we
had lots of different languages every
little valley had a different language
and people
came in contact with each other and
learned each other's languages through
imitation and then of course gradually
in each country there was only one
language
and so people didn't come into contact
as much with people speaking a different
language but we're now back into a
global village thanks to the internet
thanks through the to the diffusion of
all of these
media
uh you know uh multimedia products uh in
different languages and so i can read my
portuguese newspaper my chinese
newspaper right here sitting at home so
that's the kind of research and
technology that has brought us
to a better language learning
environment including the internet
including link
but i really do believe that the
linguistics research the research and
how we learn and all that kind of stuff
is largely a waste of time
and probably more than that
counterproductive because it over
complicates something that is really
quite straightforward and always has
been thank you for listening bye for now